this episode is brought to you by energy
sage
the nation's most trusted online solar
marketplace
head to energysage.com to start
exploring rooftop and community solar
options
in your area
[Music]
there are many organisms in nature that
are capable of
lighting themselves up through their own
bioluminescent means
but not many have the distinction of
having helped guide a future astronaut
to safety jim lovell is perhaps best
known for his flights
to and around the moon including the
1970 apollo 13 mission
which experienced a critical failure
that prevented it from actually landing
on the moon
but in 1954 he was a fighter pilot on a
training mission
off the coast of japan when his
navigation systems failed
with darkness around him and no guide to
the aircraft carrier he was meant to
land on
lovell turned off the lights in his
cabin
only to notice a glimmer of green and
the waters below
acting like a trail of glow-in-the-dark
breadcrumbs left behind by the carrier
as it moved through the water
[Music]
that light was the bioluminescence of
planktonic life
and fortunately you do not have to be a
stranded fighter pilot to see it in
action
that surface oceanic light is most
likely attributable
to a certain kind of single-celled
eukaryote called a dinoflagellate
there are more than 2 000 living species
of dinoflagellates
and while a few are found in fresh water
most
are some form of marine plankton
dinoflagellates
survive on a mix of diets some are
purely phototrophic consuming
food produced by their own chloroplasts
but most
are mixotrophic meaning that they rely
on a mix
of photosynthesis and consumption
in either capacity dinoflagellates are
hugely important for their local
ecosystems as marine primary producers
they are second only to diatoms and when
dinoflagellates consume
other organisms they link together
various facets of production and
consumption in the ocean
sending energy up the food chain but
nature
is built on balance and excess
dinoflagellates can also become
disruptive to local ecosystems when they
accumulate into large
toxic blooms also known as red tides
these can choke off resources to other
animals and sometimes
even produce toxins that poison their
neighbors
aside from their importance
dinoflagellates are kind of
quirky for one thing they have a really
weird nucleus
like so weird that it has its own name
the dino carry-on
if dino carry-on sounds majestic to you
well
that is apt the dino-carrion can hold a
truly
absurd amount of dna for a eukaryotic
nucleus
a human nucleus just for reference holds
about three picograms of dna
meanwhile some dinoflagellate species
can hold
somewhere from 100 to 200 picograms of
dna in their dino carrion
and where most eukaryotes pack our dna
into little structures connected
together like beads on a string
dinoflagellate dna does not have
that clear of an architecture even more
weird
they have the genes to make that kind of
orderly arrangement possible
they just rarely seem to use them
dinoflagellates also swim kind of funny
it's part of why we can't show them too
often because they're always whirling in
and out of focus
one of their flagella is held in a
structure around the organism's equator
spinning and moving the organism forward
the other flagella
which you can see here coming out the
end of the dinoflagellate
helps the organism steer around while
most dinoflagellates are capable of
photosynthesis
they do not all go about their
chloroplasts the same way
yes some dinoflagellates have their own
chloroplasts and used them as you would
expect to carry out photosynthesis
but others like the freshwater
nesotidinium
are a little bit less honest they
steal their chloroplasts these
dinoflagellates
start out chloroplasts and colorless
but as they begin to consume their
favorite meal
some of the local photosynthetic algae
the dinoflagellates
don't just consume their nutrients they
steal
the algae's chloroplasts these
appropriately enough
are called kleptochloroplasts and
they'll stay with the dinoflagellate
until they divide
and the daughter cells have to steal
some new ones
but of course the most striking
dinoflagellate trait is their
bioluminescence
when the organisms were first described
by henry baker in the 19th century he
called them
animal cules which caused the sparkling
light
in sea water that sparkling light is the
product of a molecule called
luciferin which is usually set into
glowing action by some kind of
mechanical stimulation it could be the
breaking of waves
a passing aircraft carrier or most
relevant to the dinoflagellates
themselves
a potential predator scientists have
hypothesized that dinoflagellates flash
their lights as a kind of burglar alarm
in response to predators attracting the
attention of other organisms that will
eat the dinoflagellates
own enemies so no they're not scaring
away their predators
they are attracting the predators of
their predators
this system of bioluminescence and the
molecules underlying it has its
parallels across a lot of other animals
including fireflies
and whether they are taking in light for
photosynthesis
or producing it through their own
pathways dinoflagellates
have evolved their own mastery of
illumination
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you again to
energysage
for sponsoring this video energysage
is the nation's most trusted online
solar marketplace
used by millions of consumers every year
they help people make smart energy
decisions and make the process of going
solar as
easy as booking a flight online leading
to
on average twenty percent lower prices
than you'd find anywhere else whether
you're a homeowner or business
electricity costs can make up a large
portion of your expenses
with a solar panel system you will
generate your own power
for the system's 25-year life cycle
plus you'll be reducing your carbon
footprint in the process
and with energy sage's easy to use
website you can compare solar proposals
receive multiple quotes from
pre-screened installers
and talk to their team of expert
unbiased energy advisors
who can answer your questions and help
you navigate your
solar journey so head on over to
energysage.com today to see how much
you can save by going soar if you ever
think to yourself
boy i sure do like this channel i wonder
who i can thank for that
well these people on the screen right
now they are those people
our patrons on patreon who make it
possible for this whole team to come
together
to make this special little show for
youtube if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes james weiss check
out jam and germs on instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
um